As a gangly kid who had just arrived
in the U.S. from Cameroon, 16
year-old Joel Embiid had a lot of
the gifts that he'd eventually put
to use in the NBA.
The height, the athleticism, that
massive seven foot six
wingspan. But the one thing that he
couldn't do was actually shoot
a basketball.
Embiid didn't get into the game at
all until he was about 15.
Today he has become not just
the linchpin of a championship
chasing team in Philadelphia.
He's also arguably the best
basketball player on the planet
and he was recently named the NBA's
Most Valuable Player for the current
season.
2023 MVP
from the Philadelphia 76ers.
It's possible that this never would
have happened if it weren't for
YouTube. In a 2016 interview
with Sports Illustrated Embiid
shared the secret to his success
learning to shoot long distance
shots by watching, in his words,
videos of regular white
people on the Internet.
When you want to when you look at
the best shooters of all time,
you know there is a common,
there is a common theme.
She is going to be in the shooting
mode.
So basically the idea is most
players, when they shoot, they set
the ball up here on their shoulder.
Footwork is our foundation.
Footwork is everything.
We're stepping into our shot.
Yes, Embiid is a big dude,
but there are a lot of those in the
NBA. What sets him apart is
his ability to do more than just
stand under the basket and dunk.
For a seven-footer, he's got an
incredibly efficient jump shot.
During his career, Embiid has sunk
more than 33% of his three
point attempts.
Now no one's going to confuse him
with Steph Curry, but that's a
better shooting percentage than
Michael Jordan.
And it's miles ahead of other guys
Embiid's size, most
of whom hardly ever score that far
from the basket.
And for that, he credits YouTube.
Now you and I are unlikely to become
professional basketball players by
watching hours of white dudes
shooting three pointers tonight.
Sorry. But you might learn how to
repair a leaky toilet or install
a utility sink in your basement by
watching YouTube.
I did.
Every day, untold numbers
of people are accomplishing less
audacious tasks because of the
knowledge that others make freely
available via all sorts of online
platforms from Wikipedia to Tik
Tok. The incredible amount
of free knowledge that's available
online is staggering,
and that knowledge confers agency
on anyone who's willing to use it.
Are there cranks on YouTube
spreading silly conspiracies and
crazy uncles on Facebook sharing Q
and on memes?
Of course, when politicians
call for regulating social media and
other online platforms, they risk
throwing out a lot of the good with
the bad.
Often in the name of protecting
children, they ought to consider the
other side of that equation too.
Being exposed to unfamiliar ideas
can sometimes be scary, but
like it was for 16 year-old
Joel Embiid trying to refine his
untapped athletic potential.
It can also be game changing.